ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนรีเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงเท้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
จันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11 ค่ะวันที่ 11
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะตีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะผชอะไรหรือผชเท่าไหร่
ได้นะโอเคโอเคเท่าไหร่ก็โอเคนะคะไรค่ะ
แล้วแต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
ตอนนี้เวลา
15:00 น
44 นาทีค่ะบ่าย3โมง 44 นาทีนใส่ค่ะวัน
นี้เรามีนักเรียนที่คน
วันนี้เรามีนักเรียน 1  2  3  4  5  6  7
8  9  10  11
11 คนค่ะ 11 คนนะคะ
11 เราจะมีคนที่ 12 เร็วๆนี้
ชายเรารอ
12-12-12 ส่งอีเมล์มาสวัสดีแล้ว
ออยกำลังมากำลังมาชื่อ
ถ้าคุณซาร่าคุณสาระมาเร็วๆศาลาส่งอีเมล
บอกสวัสดีทุกคนค่าน้องสวัสดีค่ะสาหล้า
สวัสดีค่ะก็สวัสดีนักเรียนวันนี้นะคะครู
เอ๋
ครูหญิงเนี่ยมีมีอ่ามีคำ
วันนี้ครูเอ๋ไม่มีคำถามครูหญิงมีคำถามนะ
คะครูหญิงอยากรู้จักนักเรียนอ๋อรู้จัก
แล้วคุณแบรดคุณโรเบิร์ตรูปรู้จักชื่อรู้
จักรู้จักคุณ Bad คนอเมริกา
รู้จักประเทศแล้วกอดคุณแบรดเป็นผู้ชายอ่ะ
อ๋อรู้แล้ว
อ้าวแล้วครูหญิงอยากรู้อะไร
อยากรู้
ครอบครัวคุณแปรแล้สนะนี้คุณแปร๊บแล้วก็
คุณพ่อคุณแม่
ค่ะมากคุณพ่อคุณแม่คุณ Bag มีพี่มีน้อง
อยากรู้จักเพราะอยากรู้ว่าคุณแบรดมีพี่มี
น้องกี่คนนะคะใช่ค่ะครูเองผู้หญิงครูเอก
ก็อยากรู้นี้หนูนัดเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยมี
ราได้ไหมมีนักเรียนมีกระดาษนี้ปากกา
ประกาศอ่อนนักเรียนพยักหน้าเหงาตาค่ะอะนะ
ว่าแล้วต้องเขียนหรือยกมือบอกครูหญิงกับ
ครูเอ๋นักเรียน 9 ยกมือยกกระดาษนะคะนาย
ค่ะนะคะรู้เหรอครูเอ๋อยากรู้จักใครก่อนคะ
นักเรียน 11 คนโอเคครูเอ๊ะถามนะอ่ะผู้
หญิงอยู่นะคะได้ค่ะป้าเดี๋ยวนะกูเห็นดู
ก่อนใครดีโอเค
ผู้หญิงก่อนเลยค่ะโปรอยากรู้ผู้หญิง
ใครคะรู้จักคุณประวีณาน้องคุณประวีณาคะ
คุณประวีณามีพี่มีน้องกี่คนคะน้องคุณ
ปวีณาเนี่ยยกมือ
ผมขอ
4 คนคุณประวีณามีที่ที่น้อง 4 คนอ๋อก็
รวมคุณปวีณาด้วยใช่ไหมคะอร่อยค่ะคนไทย
เนี่ยรวมคุณปวีณาแล้วก็จะมี 1  2  3 ถัก
ครบแล้วนี่ 4 คน
พี่น้องก็คือประวีณ์นานแล้วก็พี่น้องประ
วีณารวมกันที่มีพี่น้องทั้งหมด 4 คนคุณ
ประวีณานาดมีพี่น้อง 4 คน
อ่ะ
คุณประวีณาเป็นคนที่เท่าไหร่คะ
คุณปวีณาเป็นคนที่ 4 ค่ะปวีณาบอกเป็นคน
ที่ 4 ผู้หญิงคนที่ 4 คนก็พูดว่าอะไรคะ
เป็นลูกคนเล็กอ่ะลูกคนเล็กแต่ไม่ใช่ตัว
เล็กนะฮะสวยๆ
ไม่ใช่ตัวตัวใหญ่ไม่ใช่คุณปวีณาเป็นรูปคน
เล็กอาอารู้คนเล็กนั้นคุณประวีณาก็มีพี่
กี่คนคะผู้หญิงคุณปวีณามีที่ที่หนึ่งสอง
สามสามคนค่ะอ๋อ
คุณประวีณาคะพี่พี่คนโต
คนโตโต้หึง
มายด์เค้าคะ
คุณปวีณาบอกว่าพี่คนโตเป็นผู้หญิงขอผู้
หญิงนี่พี่อะไรคะพี่สาว
เมื่อกี้สาวพี่คนที่สองเป็นผู้หญิงหรือ
ผู้ชายคะ
ออกเป็นผู้ชาย
ก็เป็นพี่ชายค่ะพี่ชายพี่คนที่ 3 เป็นผู้
หญิงหรือผู้ชายคะ
คิผู้ชายค่ะผู้ชายผู้หญิงคะคุณประวีณามี
พี่สาวกี่คนคะมีพี่สาว 1 คน
มีพี่ชายกี่คนมีที่ชายสองคนคุณประวีณามี
พี่ทั้งหมดกี่คนมีพี่ทั้งหมด 3 คนฮ้อนร็ค
พี่คนกลางเป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายพี่
มีคนกลางเป็นผู้ชายเป็นผู้ชายพี่คนโตเป็น
ผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายพี่คนโตเป็นผู้หญิงเป็น
ผู้หญิงคุณประวีณาเป็นผู้หญิงเป็นผู้หญิง
เป็นลูกคนเล็กลูกคนเล็กบางที่พูดลูกคนสุด
ท้อง
คนเล็กคนสุดท้องโอเคนะอ้าไม่มีน้องแล้ว
ค่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอยากจะถามใครคะครูผู้
หญิงอยากถามคุณ
John เท็กซัสคุณ John แท็กสั้นคุณ John
เช็คสั้นมีพี่น้องกี่คนคะขอบคุณจรยกมือ 3
อ๊อด 3 คอน
ขออีกมือคุณแม่
แล้วก็พี่น้อง 3 คนอ้าคุณจอห์นเป็นลูกคน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
คุณจอนบอก
สามอ้าวเป็นลูกคนเล็ก
เหมือนคุณปวีณา
ก็ดีอ่าคุณ John มีพี่พี่คนโตเป็นผู้หญิง
หรือผู้ชายคะคุณจอนบอกว่าเป็นผู้ชายอ๋อมี
พี่ชายนะถ้าพี่คนที่สองเป็นผู้หญิงหรือ
ผู้ชายคะคุณจอนบอกว่าเป็นผู้หญิงพี่สาว
ค่ะอะพี่สาวครูหญิงคะคุณ John
มีพี่ชายกี่คน
มีพี่ชาย 1 คนก็มีพี่สาวกี่คนมีพี่สาว 1
คนแล้วคุณ John มีน้องชายไหมคะคนจรไม่มี
น้องชายมีน้องสาวไหมคะไม่มีน้องสาวไม่มี
น้องสาวคุณจอห์นเป็นลูกคนคนเล็กใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะเป็นลูกคนเล็กหรือว่าลูกคนสุดท้อง
แล้วหาลูกคนสุดท้องลูกคนเล็กนะคะถามทาง
โอเค
นี่เค้าทำอีกหรอขอโทษผู้หญิงจำได้ดีอ่ะ
คุณซ้อน
พี่สาวของคุณจอห์นเป็นลูกคนโต
หรือลูกคนกลาง
ก็พี่สาวคุณจอห์นเป็นลูกคนกลางเป็นลูกคน
กลางนะคะโอเคค่ะเสร็จแล้วแม่คนต่อไปขลุ่ย
อยากรู้พี่น้องใครคะคุณเคล้าคุณเคล้าคุณ
เข้ายิ้มห่าคนเขาคะคุณเขามีพี่น้องกี่คน
คะก็คุณเค้าบอกว่าคุณเค้ามีพี่น้อง 4 คน
หนึ่ง
ตาย 4 คน
คุณเขาเป็นลูกคนที่เท่าไหร่คะคุณเขาบอก
ว่าเป็นรูปคนที่ 2 ค่ะบุ้งคนที่คนที่สอง
เรียกลูกคนที่ 2 โอ๊ยลูกคนกลางโอเคไหม
โอเคนะคนกลางถ้า 3 คนน่ะคนกลางเลยแต่ถ้า 4
คนก็คนโตคนเล็กคนกลาง
[เพลง]
กลางค่ะจะพูดลูกคนที่สองก็โอเคนะคะคุณ
เค้าพี่พี่คนโตเป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะ
พี่คนโตเป็นผู้หญิงค่ะพี่สาวพี่สาวโอเค
น้องอันนี้คุณเขาออกพี่สาวคุณเค้าน้อง
น้องคนติดกับคุณเพราเป็นน้องชายหรือน้อง
สาวคะ
n น้องสาวค่ะเป็นน้องสาวนะคะคุณเค้าเนาะ
มีคนน้องคนเล็กเป็นน้องชายหรือน้องสาวคะ
เป็นน้องชายค่ะน้องชายอ๋อผู้หญิงคะคุณ
เคล้ามีพี่กี่คนคะมีพี่หนึ่งคนมีพี่สาว
กี่คนมีพี่สาว 1 คนมีที่ชายไหมคะไม่มีพี่
ชายค่ะไม่มีคุณเค้ามีน้องกี่คนคะนี่น้อง
122 คนค่ะมีน้องสาวกี่คนมีน้องสาว 1 คน
มีน้องชายกี่คนมีน้องชาย 1 คนคุณเขามีพี่
น้องทั้งหมดกี่คนโป้ขาคุณคราวมีพี่น้อง
ทั้งหมด 4 คนค่ะ
ผู้เยอะเนาะ
ต่อไปค่ะใครคะผู้หญิงคุณ Jae  Hee คุณจะ
บอกผมผมๆแต่อยากจะบอก
เต้ฮี่ครับ
พา
คุณไปมี
พี่น้องกี่คนคะคุณเจ๊ฮีบอกว่าว่ามีพี่
น้อง 1 คนนะเขาเรียกหนึ่งคนมั้ย
ไม่มีพี่น้องอ้าวแล้วพูดอะไรคุณเตะคน
เดียวลูกโทนอ๋อ
ลูกโทนลูกลูกโทษนะไม่หารูปโทนโทนถ่ายรูป
คนเดียวโอเคไหมคะได้ค่ะลูกคนเดียวรูปโทน
โอเคไม่มีพี่ไม่มีน้อง
อ้อคุณใจดี
คุณแตงคีย์อยากเหมือนคุณเค้าคุณประวีณา
คุณ John มีพี่มีน้องคุณเจนไตน์คนไอ้เจอ
น่ะหมดแล้วหมดแล้วลูกโอนลูกคนเดียวนะคะ
ผู้หญิงอยากจะรู้พี่น้องใครคะคุณโอคุณโอ
นักเรียนคนที่ 11 ของเราคุณคนที่สิบเอ็ด
ครูเห็นลืมชื่อคนที่ 11 คุณโอ๋ตัว
เอเลี่ยนคุณโอโอเคคุณโอโอ้โหเหี๊ยใครใคร
คุณโอถ้าคุณโอคะคุณโอมีพี่น้องกี่คนคะ
คุณโอบอกว่ามีพี่น้อง 2 คน
122 คนสองคนนะสองคนเอ่อคุณโอเป็นคนโต
หรือคนเล็กคะชิงโอก็คุณโอบอกเป็นลูกคนโต
คุณโตคุณโอเป็นรูปลูกคนโตเป็นพี่สาวเนาะ
เป็นพี่สาวโอกาสน้องคุณโอกเป็นน้องชาย
หรือน้องสาวคะ
น้องสาวค่ะ
งูคุณโอ๋ก็มีน้องสาวคุณโอ๋อื่นพี่สาวขาด
เป็นพี่คนโตไม่มีพี่นะ
ไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีน้องชายน้องทรายไม่มีมี
น้องสาวดีมากตายคุณโอเป็นลูกคนโต
น้องสาวเป็นลูกคนเล็ก
ใส่ค่ะเพราะเราไม่ถามอายุใช่ไหมไม่ถาม
แล้ว
โอเคอ้าต่อไปครูหญิงอยากจะรู้พี่น้องของ
ใครคะคุณโรเบิร์ตแพททินสัน
นะคะคุณโรเบิร์ตขาเดี๋ยวๆก็ไม่ต้อง
เปลี่ยนคะครูเอ๋เอ้าครู S คุณโรเบิร์ตแพท
ทินสันเนาะแพททินสันหล่อนะค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ต
ค่ะ
ดิสก์
คุณโรเบิร์ตมีพี่น้องพี่น้อง
มี
ทั้งหมดกี่คนคะอ๋อคุณโรเบิร์ตบอกมีพี่
น้องทั้งหมด
๓ คน
หนึ่งคนไปค่ะ 3 คนคุณโรเบิร์ตขา
[เพลง]
หญิง
คุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นลูกคนที่เท่าไหร่คะอ้าคุณ
โรเบิร์ตบอกเป็นลูกคนที่ 1 ค่ะ
คุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นรูปคนโตโอ้โหเหมือนคุณโอ
อาร์
คุณโอ๋ลูกคุณโอเป็นพี่ชายเดี๋ยวลูกโตๆ
เหมือนกันคุณโรเบิร์ตน้องคนที่ 1 นะค่ะ
ผลิตน้องคนรองเนาะงูน้องคนลองเป็นผู้หญิง
หรือผู้ชายคะคุณโรเบิร์ตถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงก็
เป็นน้องสาวใช่ไหมคะครูหญิงกะมีน้องสาว
น้องๆคนรองเป็นน้องสาวและน้องคนเล็กเป็น
น้องสาวหรือน้องชายคะคุณโรเบิร์ตบอกเป็น
น้องสาวค่ะ
คุณโรเบิร์ตมีน้องสาว 2 คนโห่ร้องไห้
เหมือนต้องมีหนวดนะใช่คุณรบโรเบิร์ตไม่
รู้จะวิ่งแข่งกับใคร
มีน้องสาว 2 คนนะคะ
น้องสาวต้องวิ่งแข่งกับโรเบิร์ตน้องเหรอ
แรงแล้วก็เล่นบท
กับโรเบิร์ต
คุณโรเบิร์ตก็เป็นพี่พี่ชายแล้วก็มีน้อง
สาว 2 คนก็มีพี่น้องกี่คนคะมีพี่น้อง 3
คน
คุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นลูกคนโตค่ะมีคำถามมีคำขาว
มีคำถามอะไรคะครูเอ๋หล่อมากค่ะหล่อ
โรเบิร์ตแพททินสันนะคะหล่อมากกว่าครูปิด
ทองเหรอคะ
ชอบชอบค่ะ
น้องอยากรู้น้องสาวสวยไหมคะคุณระเบิด
สวยอุ้ยไม่ได้สวยสวยๆเฮ้ยออกคุณโรเบิร์ต
บอกน้องสาวคุณโรเบิร์ตเห็นเด็กเด็กคิดไม่
สวยออหรอถ้าครูเห็นครูเอ๋
คิดสวยใช่ไหมถ้าคุณโดยเกิดมีรูปไหมคะรูป
ถ่ายรูปของน้องกูหลาว Robert บอกหยิบ
โทรศัพท์
กูอ่านดูนะคะไม่ดูอ่ะ
หมีค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตให้ดูน้องสาว 2 คนสวย
ไว้ว่าเออคุณโรเบิร์ตสวย
สวยๆนะคุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นพี่แล้วก็มีน้องสาว
สวย 2 คนนะคะไข่ค่ะอ่ะต่อไปอยากจะรู้พี่
น้องใครค่ะ
คุณแคทขาดผู้หญิงบางคุณแพทคุณแคทคุณแคทมี
พี่น้องกี่คนคะออกคุณแคทบอกว่ามีพี่น้อง 3
คนค่ะ 1  2
อยู่ 3 คนเหมือนคุณโรเบิร์ต
คุณแคทเป็นคนที่เท่าไหร่คะ
คุณแคทบอกว่าเป็นคนที่สองก็เป็นคนกลางอ่ะ
เป็นลูกคนกลางค่าเป็นลูกคนกลางมาหานี้
แล้วพี่คนโตไม่ใช่พี่เป็นพี่สาวหรือพี่
ชายคะก็พี่คนพี่เป็นพี่สาวค่ะคุณจะบอกพี่
สาวคุณแคท
น้องคุณแคทเป็นน้องสาวหรือน้องชายคะคุณ
แคทบอกว่าเป็นน้องสาวค่ะ
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงดีไหมดีค่ะลูกสาว
คุณพ่อคุณแม่มีลูกดีแล้วลูกสาวลูกสาวลูก
สาว 3 คนหุ้น Cat เป็นพี่สาวมีน้องสาว 2
คนราคาช่องเป็นคนกลางตาไว้ดี
คุณแคทเป็นคนกลางมีพิษมีพี่สาวกี่คนพรมี
น้องสาวกี่คนคะ
มีพี่น้อง 3 คน
โอเคไม่ดีเปลี่ยนแว่น
หรือว่าที่นี่มันมีไฟ
อ้าโอเคคุณครูผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอยากจะรู้ที่
น้องของใครอีกคะคุณทาดาชิค่ะเปลี่ยนเป็น
ผู้ชอยบ้างผู้ชายผู้ชายมีผู้ชายเราต้อง
พูดดีๆคุณหมอชิขา
เดี๋ยวๆค่ะคุณแคทคะ
คุณโรเบิร์ตขา
โอ้โหพูดไม่เหมือนกันคุณธนาชิขา
ลูกค้าว่ามากขายาว
คุณธนาชิขาอุ่นภาระที่เด็กๆนะ
อานาชิคุณใช้ดาชิคะ
คุณถ่ายราชิมีพี่น้องกี่คนคะก็คุณทาดาชิ
บอกว่ามีที่น้องสองคนสองคนนะคะคุณธาราชิ
เป็นพี่หรือเป็นน้องคะคุณทาดาชิเบาะอ๋อ
เป็นน้องอ๋อ
ถ้าคุณธนาชิเป็นน้องเป็นลูกคนเล็กค่ะเป็น
ลูกคนเล็กคุณธราชิที่เป็นพี่สาวหรือพี่
ชายคะคุณทาดาชิบอกว่าเป็นพี่ชาย
ไม่มีพี่สาว
ไม่มีน้องสาวไอ้มีน้องชายไม่มีค่ะมี 2 คน
นะคะโอเคอะ
วิ่งแข่งกันได้ได้นะพี่ชายน้องชายเหมือน
กันนะคะคุณทาดาชิก็เป็นลูกคนเล็กก็คุณ
ทาชิที่ชายหล่อไหมคะ
หล่อมากหรอเปล่าผู้หญิงพูดอ่ะ
อาโก๊ะดูคุณทาดาชิหล่อคิดดีที่ชายหล่อค่ะ
โอเคเหมือนคุณโรเบิร์ตแพททินสันหล่อน้อง
สาวสวยใช่ไหมคะใครค่ะครูเอ๋ขอบคุณค่ะคุณ
ทาชิผู้หญิงอยากจะรู้พี่น้องใครอีกคะได้
อีกมึงมีคุณ John งั้นคุณ John เลยละกัน
คุณ John สวีเดน
คุณ John สวีเดนมีพี่น้องกี่คนคะคุณจอน
บอกว่าก็มีพี่น้อง 3 คน
1  2  3  3 คน
แล้ว
คุณจอห์นเป็นลูกคนที่เท่าไหร่คะคุณจอห์น
เป็นโอ๊ยลูกคนที่สองข้าเป็นลูกคนที่ 2
คุณ John
คุณจอห์นพี่เป็นพี่สาวหรือพี่ชายคุณจอน
บอกว่าเป็นพี่สาวค่ะมีสาวแล้วน้องเป็น
น้องสาวหรือน้องชาย
เป็นน้องชายค่ะคุณจอห์นก็มีพี่สาว 1 คน
น้องชาย 1 คนมีพี่น้องทั้งหมด
3 คุณจอยเป็นรูปคนกลางนะคะเป็นลูกคนกลาง
หรือเป็นลูกคนที่ 2 ได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะหนึ่ง
สองสามได้
งั้นคุณ John ต่อไปเหลือใครค่ะอ่ะสี
เหลืองคุณลิซ่าค่ะอีก 1 คนคุณลิซ่า
ลิซ่าขาโต๊ะ
ได้ค่ะคุณลิซ่าขาคนเล็กซ่ามีพี่น้องกี่คน
คะคุณลิซ่าบอกว่ามีพี่น้อง 2 คนค่ะร้อง
ตอนปิดเครียดอะไรนะสองคนก็ Lisa เป็นคนโต
หรือคนเล็กคะ
คุณลิซ่าบอกว่าเป็น
คนเล็กค่ะคนเล็กนะคะเป็นลูกคนเล็กแล้วพี่
คนนิซ่าพี่สาวหรือพี่ชายคะคุณลิซ่าบอกว่า
เป็นพี่ชายค่ะขี้ชายนะคะคุณลิซ่ามีพี่ชาย
กี่คนคะคุณลิซ่ามีผู้ชายหนึ่งคน
มีพี่สาวกี่คนคะคุณลิซ่าไม่มีพี่สาวค่ะมี
น้องสาวกี่คนคะไม่มีน้องสาวค่ะมีน้องชาย
กี่คนคะไม่มีน้องชายค่ะเพราะว่ามีพี่ชาย
คนเดียวนะคะเพื่อ Lisa เป็นลูกคนเล็ก
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงนักเรียนยกมือยกมืออะไร
อะไรคะณตอนนี้ก็นักเรียนถามนักเรียนมีคำ
ถามอะไรคะครูเอ๋ครูหญิงมีพี่น้องกี่คนอ๋อ
อ๋อนักเรียนอยากรู้
รูหญิงมีพี่น้อง 1  2  3  3 มาช่าครูหญิง
เป็นลูกคนที่เท่าไหร่คะผู้หญิงเป็นลูกคน
โต
คนโตผู้หญิงข้าล่ะน้องคนกลางเป็นผู้หญิง
หรือผู้ชายเป็นผู้ชายค่ะเป็นน้องชายเป็น
ภาษาสายน้องคนเล็กเป็นน้องชายหรือน้องสาว
เล่นน้องชายค่ะผู้หญิงก็มีน้องชาย 2 คน
ใส่ค่ะก็ดีมากใช่ไหมผู้หญิงเป็นใครเรา
เป็นมาเฟียบาร์บี้บาร์บี้บาร์บี้
อะไรวะ
น้องชายเล่นขับรถอ่ะเล่นบาร์บี้
เหรียญครูหยีเอาบาร์บี้โอเค
มาเปลี่ยนโอเคคุยอิ๋งวันนี้เวลาทั้งหมด
แล้วหมดเวลาเพราะเราก็รู้ว่านักเรียนเป็น
ลูกคนโตเป็นลูกคนกลางหรือว่าเป็นลูกคน
เล็กในว่าบางคนเป็นลูกโทนลูกเหล่านี้ไป
ค่ะค่ะวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเจอ
กันวีดีโอหน้านะคะ 5 สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
อ่ะ